Okay, so this is that same table?
but now
we have relative frequencies.
How do we how do we get from this? How do we get
to frequencies to relative frequencies? Well, if for
example
A and B had five elements in common, we would divide 5 over
100 and that would give us
well 0.05.
And then we do the same thing. We divide all of the marginal.
and relative frequencies
by 100 and that's how we get these.
decimal numbers
Which is how we get to which is how
we go from relative frequency to probability anyway.
now
remember that the
Remember the formula for the Bayesian theorem.
I'm gonna actually copy it over here.
Now this is still this is still conditional probability.
But once we understand
the
terms
and how we would extract the values for these
terms from the table.
Then we can talk about deriving the base theorem the
formula for the Bayesian theorem.
so first, let's
write down the marginal probabilities. So
these are the
the first two are the marginals
and the second two are
the joint
We have marginal probabilities joint probability the
probabilities and now we see how we get the conditional probabilities.
So the joint probability of a well, we just look
at the margins and that's this one over here.
the probability of B is 10
and if you want to do not A and B we get
35 or a and 94 B
and if you want to know what what their joint probability disorder will
again, we can just look up the table.
So A and B. That's 5.
Again, they had five elements in common if we divide by 100 that
gives us five or five percent.
Over here if you if you notice I'm using.
The letter c on top of B.
There are different ways to
Express the complement you can use till day
next to the element or put excuse me
till they next to the letter or I vertical
line above the letter or put a
c.
at the top
So there are different ways to use the complement. I've actually done I've
had to do this because when I use it
till they character the spacing doesn't work out well, so
I just
alternative we have used the letter c but they're
the same thing.
This is a complement of B.
This is the complement of B.
I've only changed the notation because of the
document formatting.
They are interchangeable. They are the same exact thing.
It's like multiplication you can use what you
can use.
The X symbol from multiplication or you can put a dot
or can put an asterisk or it can
just put two letters next to each other and that's still multiplication.
Okay, but let's carry on.
Let's see how we can get to conditional probability. Well
conditional probability says that
the probability of event a
occurring given event B
is given by
the intersection of those two events over
the hypothesis
Again, let me read this again. So we read this as
the probability the probability of a given that vertical
line is given given B.
And that's how we express it.
Why do we have the module probability B
in the denominator?
Because when a certain event occurs, we're saying
given event B.
the total number of possible outcomes
Is the total number of possible outcomes?
Of the event B.
so
here's another way to think about it, right?